your brothers and sisters in the slum
net from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even more we
want to ask you one final question and
you can answer together individually
because it's how I like to end all my
podcasts how would you like to be
remembered
brother
take your time because we can edit this
photo yeah okay now I want you to think
I actually think about this quite a lot
I'll be honest because there is a there
is a prophetic saying what a prophet
Muhammad said
that all of the the Deeds of human being
is cut except for three things
a child who is a righteous child that
will make supplication for them
a continual charity
a beneficial knowledge that people will
benefit from
now what I want to do before I die is I
want to have something
Left Behind for the people that they
will benefit from it's not about how I
want to be remembered it's about what
I'm going to leave behind will be used
useful there's a beautiful verse in the
Quran yeah it's in chapter 13.
where she goes like the part of the
verse is like this
as for the foam of the sea it just
evaporates where a mermaid and foundness
as for that which benefits the people it
stays on the Earth
like if you think about all the
inventions of humankind
necessity is the mother of all invention
most of the inventions that we're using
now have actually been created or
invented in the war period because you
need to have like a phone you need to
have this you need to have that
so these things because people were just
they were obsessed with creating things
of use I actually heard Kanye West
saying this in a recent interview he was
saying I don't want to be remembered he
was asked the same question he goes I
don't want to be remembered the person
who who done the the the the the the the
lamp post was not remembered this one
that was wasn't remembered but what they
have in place is used so for me it's not
necessarily about me being remembered as
much as it is leaving something of use
for people to use because in my opinion
when I'm dead three things will continue
my my progeny we talked about
propagating your genes in your progeny
so I want to teach my children so that
they can continually pray for me and
remember me and so on number two is a
continual charity which means it's not a
charity that ceases so for example a
water well or a school or something like
that something that when I'm dead
because a statue is not what I speak you
know what I'm trying to say people want
to be remembered in the form of a statue
or something like that no it's not she's
not going to speak but a a a a a a
school is going to produce people who
are going to speak so I want to have
something like that continual that I
started this up you know what I say and
I continually getting the reward for
that after I'm dead and thirdly and I
would say most importantly
I want to have something that I've left
behind that people will continually use
say reference 100 years 200 years 300
years someone's going to be caught a new
one day Matt